EVERYBODY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THERE COMES A TIME IN EVERY
PRESIDENTIAL ADMINISTRATION
WHEN PEOPLE IN CHARGE REALIZE
THEY ARE NOT IN CONTROL.
UNFORESEEN EVENTS ARISE.
IN AN INSTANT, EVERY
ASSUMPTION CHANGES.
HEAD OF STATE DIE, NATURAL
DISASTERS AND EPIDEMICS RAGE.
NOTHING IN A PLAN.
BUT THERE IS SOMETHING THAT
PREVENT US TO PREPARE FOR
ABRUPT AND RADICAL CHANGE.
WE PREVENT THE UNEXPECTED WILL
NEVER HAPPEN.
BUT THERE IS SOMETHING IN
NATURE ITSELF TO REMIND US IT
INEVITABLY WILL.
IT’S ALWAYS A TERRIFYING
REALIZATION.
THE RISE OF THE CHINESE
CORONAVIRUS IS THAT MOBILITY.
IT’S QUICKLY BECOMING A
PANDEMIC AND IT COULD KILL
MILLIONS AND AT THE LEAST
REORDER THE GLOBAL ECONOMY AND
CHANGE OUR POLITICS.
COULD THE DISEASE HELP
DETERMINE THE OUTCOME OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION EIGHT
MONTHS FROM NOW?
OF COURSE IT COULD.
IT WILL.
THE LEADERS CAN’T STOP THAT.
LIKE ALL MATTERS OF LIFE, IT’S
BEYOND THE HUMAN POWER TO A
FACT.
BUT THEY CAN RESPOND TO A
THREAT IN A WAY THAT MAKES THE
COUNTRY STRONGER.
NOT WEAKER.
HOW?
HERE IS HOW.
THE FIRST ACCEPT IS TAKE THE
VIRUS SERIOUSLY AND CONVINCE
THE PUBLIC YOU ARE.
IN 1918, WOOD WOODROW WILSON
DOWNPLAYED THE SPANISH
INFLUENZA AND REFUSED TO TAKE
OBVIOUS CAUTION TO SLOW THE
SPREAD.
HE HAD A WAR IN EUROPE TO
FIGHT AND THE GENERALS
COULDN’T DISTRACTED FROM THE
GOAL SO THE GOVERNMENT
CONTINUED TO SHIP MEN TO THE
OVERCROWDED ARMY CAMPS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND PACK THEM ON
SHIPS TO FRANCE.
THE VIRUS SPREAD
EXPONENTIALLY.
IN THE END, 53,000 AMERICAN
SOLDIERS WERE KILLED IN COMBAT
IN THE WAR.
AT LEAST 675,000 AMERICANS
DIED OF THE FLU.
COULD WILSON HAVE PREVENTED
THAT DISASTER?
NOT ENTIRELY.
BUT BY EARLY AND DECISIVE
ACTION HE COULD HAVE IMPROVED
AMERICA’S ODDS.
WHAT DOES EFFECTIVE ACTION
LOOK LIKE NOW?
WE OUGHT TO BE SCREENING
PEOPLE WHEN THEY GET OFF THE
PLANES FROM INFECTED
COUNTRIES.
THAT IS NOT COMPLICATED.
THAT IS OBVIOUS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THAT IS
HARDLY A SOLUTION.
WE SHOULD BE HONEST ABOUT HOW
MUCH WE CAN DO TO KEEP THE
CORONAVIRUS FROM COMING HERE.
A HUNDRED YEARS AGO THE
SPANISH FLU KILLED A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF THE
POPULATION IN REMOTE ALEUTIAN
ISLANDS AND THAT WAS BEFORE
FLIGHTS.
GLOBAL PANDEMIC IS INEVITABLE.
TOO MUCH MOVEMENT TO KEEP THE
VIRUSES ISOLATED.
WE SHOULD ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
WE CAN DO OUR BEST TO KEEP THE
FOREIGN DISEASES OUT OF THE
COUNTRY BUT WE OUGHT TO SPEND
MOST OF THE TIME FIGURING OUT
HOW TO PROTECT AMERICANS ONCE
DISEASE GETS HERE.
THERE IS STILL A LOT WE DON’T
KNOW ABOUT THE CHINESE
CORONAVIRUS.
BUT TWO THINGS SEEM CLEAR.
IT’S HIGHLY COMMUNICABLE AND
THE ELDER AND THOSE WITH
PREEXISTING RESPIRATORY
DISEASE FACE THE GREATEST
THREAT FROM IT.
FOR MOST AMERICANS THE BIGGEST
RISKS WILL COME NOT FROM THE
VIRUS ITSELF BUT FROM THE
ANCILLARY EFFECTS.
PEOPLE WILL PANIC.
TRAVEL WILL BE DISRUPTED.
MARKETS WILL TUMBLE.
AND MOST CRITICALLY HOSPITALS
WILL BE OVERWHELMED.
WE ARE AT THE LIMITS OF THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
CONDITIONS WILL BE TOUGH FOR
MANY THOUSAND OF AMERICANS
LOOKING FOR BEDS TO RECOVER
FROM THE FLU.
IN SEATTLE, THEY ALREADY ARE.
BUT THINGS WILL BE WORSE FOR
ANYONE SUFFERING FROM SAY
PANCEATITIS OR BURST APPENDIX
OR OTHER HEALTH EMERGENCIES.
PEOPLE LIKE THIS MAY NOT GET
CARE AT ALL.
THE SYSTEMS WON’T BE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THEM.
IS THIS REALLY THE TIME TO
INVITE THE REST OF THE WORLD
TO JOIN MEDICARE FOR ALL?
PROBABLY NOT.
THAT IDEA WAS ALWAYS STUPID.
NOW IT’S CLEARLY DANGEROUS.
SAVING AMERICAN MEDICINE FROM
COLLAPSE MUST BE THE LEADERS’
TOP PRIORITY NOW.
WE NEED TO EXPAND EMERGENCY
HOSPITAL BED CAPACITY.
WE NEED TO MAKE CERTAIN WE
HAVE LIFE SAVING DRUGS AND
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT.
THE BASICS.
THAT IS NOT AS SIMPLE AS IT
SOUNDS OR AS IT SHOULD BE.
WELL, THE REST OF US ARE
ARGUING ABOUT TRANSGENDERED
BATHROOM AND SEXISM CHINA TOOK
CONTROL OF THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM.
CHINA DOMINATES THE WORLD
MARKET IN PHARMACEUTICAL
INGREDIENTS AND COME BOUNDS IN
EVERY ESSENTIAL MEDICINE FOR
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE, CANCER,
ALZHEIMER’S DISEASE AND MANY
MORE.
THEY COME FROM CHINA.
SO THE KEY COMPONENT IN THE
VITAL MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY, C.T.
SCANNERS, X-RAY MACHINE AND
ULTRASOUND.
AS OF TONIGHT, MORE THAN 95%
OF ALL THE ANTIBIOTICS IN
AMERICA ARE MANUFACTURED IN
COMMUNIST CHINA.
95%.
OUR CHIEF GLOBAL RIVAL HAS A
TOTAL MONOPOLY ON THE MOST
IMPORTANT MEDICINE IN THE
WORLD.
THAT SHOULD WORRY YOU MORE
THAN ANYTHING THAT CANDIDATES
ARE CURRENTLY TALKING ABOUT.
IMAGINE WATCHING ONE OF YOUR
CHILDREN DIE FROM AN INFECTED
CUT.
CHINA HAS THE POWER TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT IS
ACUTELY AWARE OF THIS POWER.
LAST YEAR A PRIMARY ECONOMIST
IN CHINA SUGGESTED CUTTING OFF
SUPPLY OF THE ANTIBIOTICS TO
THE UNITED STATES IN LEVERAGE
OF THE TRADE WAR.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE
BIGGEST STORY IN IRK MANY.
THE NEWS MEDIA ALL BUT IGNORED
IT.
WHY?
IT IMPLICATED THEM AND THEIR
POLITICAL PARTY IN ONE OF THE
GREATEST CRIMES OF OUR TIME.
NINE YEARS AGO FAMOUSLY
BRILLIANT FORMER PRESIDENT
BARACK OBAMA DID PREDICT A
CONNECTION FROM CHINA AND THE
NEXT PANDEMIC BUT HE GOT IT
BACKWARD AND CLAIMED THAT
CHINA WOULD HELP US.
>> I ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THAT
CHINA’S PEACEFUL RISE IS GOOD
FOR THE WORLD.
IT’S GOOD FOR AMERICA.
TO THE EXTENT WE HAVE A
PARTNER IN ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE OR
PANDEMIC.
>> Tucker: OUR FOREMOST
GENIUS.
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
TO THE EXTENT THEY DO, THEY
ARE SELLING US OUT ON PURPOSE.
WE SHOULD HAVE SEEN THIS
COMING.
IN RECENT WEEKS YOU HAVE HEARD
A LOT ABOUT THE DISRUPTION TO
THE SO-CALLED SUPPLY CHAINS.
THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS.
IT MEANS THAT THANKS TO THE
ECONOMIC CHANGES THAT MADE A
SMALL GROUP OF THE BUSINESS
MOGULS INCREDIBLY RICH, WE NO
LONGER MAKE THE THINGS WE NEED
TO SURVIVE AND PROSPER AS A
NATION.
PEOPLE WHO HATE US AND WHO
SEEK TO DISPLACE US MAKE THOSE
THINGS.
IT’S NOT JUST MEDICINE AND
X-RAY MACHINES.
IT’S COMPUTERS, PHONES,
ROBOTICS AND THE AUTOMOTIVE
COMPONENT, MACHINE TOOLS AND
ESSENTIAL PART FOR AIRCRAFT
ENGINE, ET CETERA.
APART FROM THE FOSSIL FUELS
IT’S EVERYTHING.
NOW YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED MANY
OF THE LEADERS TALK ABOUT
SHUTTING DOWN THE DOMESTIC
ENERGY SECTOR.
THE LAST INDEPENDENT PART OF
THE AMERICAN ECONOMY.
THIS IS SABOTAGE.
WE ARE ABOUT TO LEARN HOW
UNDERMINED WE’VE BEEN.
AT SOME POINT THE LEADERS
SHOULD BE HELD TO ACCOUNT FOR
THIS.
FOR NOW WE NEED TO WORK AS IF
THE LIVES DEPENDED ON IT AND
FIX THE PROBLEM.
GLOBAL WARMING IS NOT THE
EXISTENTIAL THREAT WE FACE.
CHINA CONTROLS US.
TO RESPOND NEED A MODERN
MARSHAL PLAN, ONE DESIGNED TO
REBUILD ESSENTIAL AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING.
WE SHOULD START TOMORROW.
WITH MEDICINE AND TECHNOLOGY
TO FIGHT THE CORONAVIRUS.
AND THEN WITH ANTIBIOTICS.
SOME WILL OPPOSE THE IDEA
BECAUSE IT POSES A THREAT TO
ARRANGEMENTS THEY CURRENTLY
BENEFIT FROM.
BUT A MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
WILL WELCOME IT GLADLY.
EVEN IN THE CONGRESS.
MANUFACTURING LIFTS EVERY
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
IT SHOULDN’T BE HARD TO WIN
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
NO DOUBT THE SAGES ON
TELEVISION WILL DENOUNCE ANY
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF CHINA’S
THREAT AS RACISM OR
INTOLERANCE.
JOE BIDEN HAS ALREADY DONE
THAT.
IGNORE THEM.
THE CHINESE CORONAVIRUS REALLY
IS CHINESE.
IT AROSE IN THAT COUNTRY FOR
SAME REASON AMERICAN
BUSINESSES SENT SO MANY OF OUR
JOBS THERE.
LAX HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS AND ENDEMIC
CORRUPTION.
CHINA DID THIS TO THE WORLD.
WE SHOULD NOT PRETEND
OTHERWISE.
THAT IS NOT XENOPHOBIA.
IT’S TRUE.
A FEW YEARS YEARS FROM NOW WHEN
LAST VICTIM OF THE VIRUS HAS
RECOVERED OR BEEN BURIED THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT COULD GRO
STRONGER AND AMERICA WEAKER.
CHINA RELEASES PANDEMIC AND
OVERTAKES THE WORLD AS A
RESULT.
THAT IS TOO HORRIBLE OUTCOME.
WE OUGHT TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO MAKE SURE IT DOESN’T
HAPPEN.
LET’S START ACCURATELY TALK
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING.
CORONAVIRUS IS NOT FLUKE.
IT’S BYPRODUCT.
THE DISEASES AND THE MASS
DESTRUCTION THEY CAUSE ARE THE
BUILT IN COST OF
CONNECTEDNESS.
THEY ALWAYS WILL BE.
THE PEOPLE THAT TOLD US THERE
IS NO DOWNSIDE TO LIVE IN A
BORDERLESS WORLD WERE LYING.
MAKE THEM EAT THEIR WORDS.
STRIP THEM OF THEIR POWER.
NEVER LISTEN TO THEM AGAIN.
IN FACT, THIS IS STILL THE
HARDEST THING FOR WASHINGTON
TO ACCEPT, THIS PANDEMIC VIND
KATES TRUMP’S POLITICAL
THESIS.
ON THE BIG THINGS TRUMP WAS
RIGHT.
TRADE, IMMIGRATION, AND
MANUFACTURING, GLOBALIZATION.
THESE ARE THE ISSUES THAT THE
RULING CLASS IGNORES AND HAS
IGNORED FOR DECADES IN FAVOR
OF THE SILLY CALCULATED
DISTRACTIONS LIKE THE GENDER
WARFARE AND RACE POLITICS.
THINGS THAT DEFY US.
TRUMP RAN ON THE ISSUES THAT
MATTER AND HE WON BECAUSE THE
PUBLIC WAS LIED TO AND HE
SHOULD REMEMBER THAT.
THE WHITE HOUSE REACTION
CORONAVIRUS SO FAR HAS BEEN
UNEVEN AND LIMP.
IT DOESN’T NEED TO BE.
THE BLUEPRINT FOR EFFECTIVE
RESPONSE, RESPONSE TO PROTECT
THE COUNTRY AND IMPROVES IS,
IS THERE ON THE 2016
ACCEPTANCE SPEECH AT THE
REPUBLICAN CONVENTION IN
CLEVELAND.
AMERICANISM NOT GLOBAL.
IGLOBALISM, HESAID.
ALL WE NEED TO DO BELIEVE IN
OURSELF AND THE COUNTRY AGAIN.
TIME TO SHOW THE WORLD THAT
AMERICA IS BACK.
BIGGER, BETTER, STRONGER THAN
EVER BEFORE.
THERE IT IS.
THAT THE GOVERNING AGENDA IN
THE AGE OF THE CHINESE
CORONAVIRUS.
ABANDON GLOBALISM.
REBUILD THE COUNTRY.
MAKE THE THINGS WE NEED.